Heads up parents, this episode contains strong language, so if you're listening with small kids, you may want to save this one for later. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In all of the drama of current politics in the United States, there is one truth that is endured through the first two years of Donald Trump's presidency. There's only one person, and that's the dog. Finally, we get someone that's not a politician. He is not afraid to say what we're holding. He's the screw you're washing with, that's all you. He has kept the support of the core group of voters who propelled him into the White House. The approval of these voters, often white and often working
各位家长请注意，本期节目包含粗俗语言，如果您正与年幼的孩子一起收听，建议您稍后再听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在美国当前政治的种种戏剧性事件中，有一个事实贯穿了唐纳德·特朗普总统任期的前两年。只有一个人，那就是那条狗。终于，我们迎来了一个不是政客的人。他敢于说出我们心里想的话。他就是那个和你一起受苦的螺丝钉，仅此而已。他保持了将他送入白宫的核心选民群体的支持。这些选民通常是白人，通常是工薪阶层，
class, has meant the Republican Party as a whole, has stayed loyal to Trump. Few Republicans running for high office can expect to win without the Trump base. As Trump himself once famously said, this week on Hidden Brain, we explored two competing perspectives on Trump's supporters and their motivations. One paints a sympathetic picture, focusing on class divisions and economic pain. This is a group that feels belittled and ignored and you know what, some level they're
这意味着共和党作为一个整体，一直忠于特朗普。很少有竞选高级职位的共和党人能在没有特朗普基本盘的情况下获胜。正如特朗普本人曾经说过的名言，本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们探讨了关于特朗普支持者及其动机的两种相互竞争的观点。一种描绘了一幅富有同情心的图景，关注阶级分化和经济痛苦。这是一个感到被轻视和忽视的群体，你知道吗，在某种程度上他们是
right. The other is more critical. Race, as we all know, is such a fundamental cleavage in our society. I think Republicans are using it to their advantage. Joan Williams studies gender, class, and work in the United States. She's currently professor of law at the University of California Hastings College of the Law. She is also the author of the book, White Working Class, Overcoming Class Cluelessness in America. Joan, welcome to Hidden Brain.
对的。另一种观点则更为批判。众所周知，种族是我们社会中一个根本性的裂痕。我认为共和党人正在利用这一点来获取优势。琼·威廉姆斯研究美国的性别、阶级和工作。她目前是加州大学黑斯廷斯法学院的法学教授。她也是《白人工薪阶层：克服美国的阶级无知》一书的作者。琼，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Delighted to be here. We've heard a lot about the White Working Class since the 2016 election. I'm wondering if you could paint a picture from me, Joan, of who you include in this group and how you distinguish them from the very wealthy and the poor? In order to understand American politics, really for the past 40 years, you need to define three different groups. One is the poor with a median annual income of around $19,000. That's the bottom 30% of Americans by household income. And then the top, the professional manager elite is the top 20% by household income. And I define that as top 20% by household income with one college grad. The group that's being called the working class is the group in the middle. It's the middle 53 percent with a median household income in the in the 70s.
很高兴来到这里。自2016年大选以来，我们听到了很多关于白人工薪阶层的信息。琼，我想请你为我描绘一下，你将哪些人归入这个群体，以及你如何将他们与非常富有的人和贫困人口区分开来？为了理解美国政治，实际上是过去40年的政治，你需要定义三个不同的群体。一个是贫困人口，家庭年收入中位数约为19,000美元。这是按家庭收入计算的美国最底层的30%。然后是顶层，专业管理精英是按家庭收入计算的前20%。我将其定义为家庭收入前20%且至少有一名大学毕业生。被称为工薪阶层的群体是中间的群体。这是中间的53%，家庭收入中位数在7万美元左右。
That's the group that's called the working class, although they actually are the middle class. You have some startling statistics about wages in this middle group over the last half century, what's happened to them economically starting, let's say, 1970? Since 1970, the wages and economic prospects of this group have absolutely tinked. Actually, more recent statistics have come out since the book, and the most dramatic is that virtually all Americans born in the 1940s did better than their parents, virtually all. But today it's less than half. And this is the group whose economic prospects has really collapsed. And that's actually true not only in the US,
这就是所谓的工薪阶层，尽管他们实际上是中产阶级。关于这个中间群体在过去半个世纪里的工资情况，你有一些惊人的统计数据，从1970年算起，他们在经济上经历了什么？自1970年以来，这个群体的工资和经济前景绝对是停滞不前。事实上，自这本书出版以来，出现了更新的统计数据，最引人注目的是，几乎所有出生于20世纪40年代的美国人都比他们的父母过得好，几乎所有人。但今天这一比例不到一半。这就是经济前景真正崩溃的群体。而且这不仅在美国是事实，
it's true in advanced industrialized countries throughout the world. A more recent study showed, and that's one of the reasons you find these populist politics arising in many places around the world, not just the United States. I want to spend some time talking about your own journey wandering across these different class boundaries, and I want to start with when you were a fairly young girl. You came from a relatively well off background, certainly by education, your family was very highly educated. But you had a boyfriend who came from the white working class and you went over to his house for dinner when you were 16. Tell me what happened next.
在世界各地的发达工业化国家也是如此。最近的一项研究表明，这也是你在世界许多地方（不仅仅是美国）看到民粹主义政治兴起的原因之一。我想花点时间谈谈你自己在这些不同阶级界限之间游走的旅程，我想从你还是个小女孩的时候开始说起。你来自一个相对富裕的背景，至少从教育程度来看，你的家庭受教育程度非常高。但你有一个来自白人工薪阶层的男朋友，你在16岁时去他家吃过晚饭。告诉我接下来发生了什么。
Yeah, I was very much a silver spoon girl. The boyfriend that I had when I was 16, he was actually extremely wealthy, but he came from a strictly working class family and his parents had grown up working class. And so I went over to dinner. I was madly in love with him at the time and very eager to impress his parents. And so I asked afterwards, how did they like me? And he said, my father said, she looked at us
是的，我当时完全是一个含着金汤匙长大的女孩。我16岁时的那个男朋友，他其实非常富有，但他来自一个纯粹的工薪阶层家庭，他的父母也是在工薪阶层长大的。所以我去吃晚饭。我当时疯狂地爱着他，非常渴望给他的父母留下好印象。所以事后我问，他们觉得我怎么样？他说，我父亲说，她看着我们
like a fucking anthropologist. And I was really shocked. First of all, I never heard an adult use that word. That's a class distinction right there. And secondly, I was really hurt because I realized that it was really true. What Joan didn't realize at the time was that her boyfriend's father had reason to see her with suspicion. As she was to later learn as a researcher, white working-class men had experience with
就像看着一个该死的人类学家。我当时真的很震惊。首先，我从未听过成年人使用那个词。那本身就是一个阶级区别。其次，我真的很受伤，因为我意识到这是真的。琼当时没有意识到的是，她男朋友的父亲有理由以怀疑的眼光看她。正如她后来作为研究人员所了解到的那样，白人工薪阶层的男性有被
social elites studying them, judging them, and finding them lacking. Today, Joan would describe what her boyfriend's father was experiencing as a loss of social honor. I asked her what she means by the term. Well, I mean, in many ways, the way to understand this is to think about WPA murals in post offices across the country. I mean, if you've ever seen them, they're murals all over, and they celebrate the dignity of blue collar work. You have strong, effective guys doing important dirty work,
社会精英研究、评判并被认为有所欠缺的经历。今天，琼会把她男朋友父亲所经历的描述为社会荣誉的丧失。我问她这个词是什么意思。嗯，我的意思是，在很多方面，理解这一点的办法是想想全国各地邮局里的WPA壁画。我的意思是，如果你见过它们，到处都是壁画，它们赞美蓝领工作的尊严。你有强壮、能干的人在做重要的脏活，
building the country, and they're really held up as one of the ideals of manliness and strength. And that was very much the cultural image of the blue collar guy until you know the 60s or 70s when it began to wane and we had a flip in the cultural imagery of blue collar men and I think of this you can see this actually through situation comedies. I mean, you think of Homer Simpson. As an emblematic of the stereotype of white working class men today, he's kind of dim-witted, amiable, fat, and ineffectual. Or if you think of Archie Bunker, a famous TV character in the 1970s. Oh, let me tell you something. I have so sick of Washington and all its works.
建设这个国家，他们确实被视为男子气概和力量的理想之一。直到60年代或70年代，这种文化形象开始衰落，蓝领男性的文化形象发生了翻转，我想你可以通过情景喜剧看到这一点。我的意思是，你想到荷马·辛普森。作为今天白人工薪阶层男性的刻板印象的象征，他有点愚笨、和蔼、肥胖且无能。或者如果你想到阿奇·邦克，20世纪70年代著名的电视角色。哦，让我告诉你一些事情。我厌倦了华盛顿及其所作所为。
Who also was dimwitted and fat, also racist and sexist. So, you have this sharp fall from social honor of blue collar men. And it's felt very deeply as a personal front. When you speak with people from the working class, one of the things you say in the book is that they feel that they're often stereotyped. The stereotype is being poorly educated. The stereotype is being ugly, coarse,
他也是愚笨、肥胖，而且种族主义和性别歧视。所以，蓝领男性在社会荣誉上出现了这种急剧下降。这被深深地感受为一种个人冒犯。当你与工薪阶层的人交谈时，你在书中提到的一点是，他们觉得他们经常被刻板印象化。刻板印象是受教育程度低。刻板印象是丑陋、粗鲁，
they have bat teeth, they're fat. I mean, these are very, very personal sort of charges, if you will, that in some ways must be experienced as a form of humiliation. I think they are form of humiliation. I think the American elite has put a lot of thought into self-correcting our stereotypes of the poor. And so it would be considered bad taste in my circles to stereotype the poor is, you know. I think that we stereotype the working class,
他们有烂牙，他们很胖。我的意思是，这些是非常、非常个人的指控，如果可以这样说的话，在某种程度上一定会被体验为一种羞辱。我认为它们是一种羞辱。我认为美国精英在自我纠正对穷人的刻板印象方面投入了很多思考。所以在我所在的圈子里，把穷人刻板印象化会被认为是品味低劣。我认为我们把工薪阶层，
especially the white working class as sort of stupid racist losers. And we use that kind of as a mute button to say, I'm not going to listen to anything, they say. But that's really a misuse of anti-racism as an excuse for snobbery. You have elite white people refusing to listen to the legitimate economic complaints of less elite white people on the grounds that those other white people are racist. You know, there's a lot of racism. You know, where you have white people, you're gonna have racism. That's the very sad
尤其是白人工薪阶层，刻板印象化为愚蠢、种族主义的失败者。我们有点把它当作静音按钮，说，我不会听他们说的任何话。但这实际上是滥用反种族主义作为势利的借口。精英白人拒绝倾听不太精英的白人的合法经济诉求，理由是那些白人是种族主义者。你知道，有很多种族主义。你知道，有白人的地方，就会有种族主义。这是这个国家非常悲哀的
history of this country. But using anti-racism as a mute button is not helping the situation. You mentioned Homer Simpson a second ago. We actually found some tape with Homer Simpson. I want you to listen to this exchange. Bump! Time to go to work! Little do they know I'm ducking out early to take the Duff Brewery tour. Rollin' at nine, punch out at five! That's the plan! They don't suspect a thing. Well, off to the plant!
历史。但把反种族主义当作静音按钮并不能解决问题。你刚才提到了荷马·辛普森。我们实际上找到了一些荷马·辛普森的录音。我想让你听听这段对话。砰！该去上班了！他们不知道我要早退去参加达夫啤酒厂的参观。九点上班，五点下班！就是这样！他们什么都不会怀疑。好了，去工厂了！
Then to the Duff Brewery. Oh, did I say that or just think it? I gotta think of a life fast! Mom, are you going to the D-brew-y? AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH in sort of an overall, you know, the overall picture is one of, of, of humor, right? I mean, these are elites making fun of people who are blue-collar people. That's right. And I mean, one of the things that blue-collar people are that ethic of self-discipline and hard work is so central to them. And they're, you know, they're very proud of their ability to go to these often not very fulfilling jobs day after day after day for 40 years straight.
然后去达夫啤酒厂。哦，我是说出来了还是只是想了想？我得快点想个借口！妈，你要去达夫啤酒厂吗？啊……（尖叫声）……总的来说，你知道，整体画面是一种幽默，对吧？我的意思是，这些是精英在取笑蓝领阶层的人。没错。我的意思是，蓝领阶层的人所具备的自律和努力工作的道德对他们来说非常重要。而且他们，你知道，他们为自己能够日复一日、年复一年地从事这些往往并不令人满足的工作长达40年而感到非常自豪。
And I think here of my father-in-law who went, did exactly that. He worked in a factory that made those machines that measure the humidity in museums and he was an inspector. He hated his job. He went to it for 40 years. And he was proud of doing a good job while he was at work. He was proud of the work that he did. And he took it seriously and he worked very hard and he deserved dignity for that.
我在这里想到了我的岳父，他就是那样做的。他在一家制造测量博物馆湿度机器的工厂工作，他是一名检查员。他讨厌他的工作。他干了40年。他为自己在工作中表现出色而感到自豪。他为自己所做的工作感到自豪。他认真对待工作，工作非常努力，他理应为此获得尊严。
And one of the things that I've been trying to explain to people is that these jobs are important jobs. When I get up in the morning and I turn on the tap, it's not because of some knowledge worker that water comes out. It's because of some blue collar person. Another thing that strikes me, and this is actually from a really fascinating article studying class and sitcoms is Marge in the Simpson is depicted as a smarter and more responsible and more grown up than Homer Simpson is and that's a pattern in American sitcoms where in if you look at professional
我一直试图向人们解释的一件事是，这些工作是重要的工作。当我早上起床打开水龙头时，水流出来并不是因为什么知识工作者。而是因为某个蓝领工人。另一件让我印象深刻的事情，这实际上来自一篇研究阶级和情景喜剧的非常迷人的文章，是《辛普森一家》中的玛吉被描绘得比荷马·辛普森更聪明、更负责任、更成熟，这是美国情景喜剧中的一种模式，如果你看情景喜剧中的专业
managerial families in sitcoms, it's father knows best and mother's a good support. But if you look at working class families in sitcoms, the woman is smarter and often the children are smarter than the dimwitted dad. So it's like kind of a class of front
管理家庭，那是“父亲最懂”，母亲是很好的支持者。但如果你看情景喜剧中的工薪阶层家庭，女性更聪明，而且孩子们通常比愚笨的父亲更聪明。所以这就像是一种阶级冒犯
and a gender front exacerbating the class of front. You and front exacerbating the class of front. You and your husband come from different backgrounds. You're the fourth generation of lawyer in your family, and you went to Yale and Harvard and MIT. Your husband came from blue collar roots. He's what you call a class migrant. Tell me about a high school reunion he once attended and the question he asked of a former classmate and what this exchange revealed to you. Yeah, so we went back to his high school reunion and, you know, I'm the anthropologist, he's not.
和性别冒犯，加剧了阶级冒犯。你和你的丈夫来自不同的背景。你是家族中第四代律师，你去了耶鲁、哈佛和麻省理工。你丈夫来自蓝领家庭。他就是你所说的阶级移民。告诉我他曾经参加过的一次高中同学聚会，以及他问一位老同学的问题，还有这次交流向你揭示了什么。是的，所以我们回到了他的高中同学聚会，你知道，我是人类学家，他不是。
So he did what he had come to be used to in uperminal class circles, he asked one of his classmates, what do you do? Absolutely the standard question, my crowd. And his classmate was really offended. The classmate put his face very close to my husband's face. He got beat red and he said, I sell toilets. And he obviously felt that the, what do you do question was a class insult from virtually the only member
所以他做了他在上层阶级圈子里习惯做的事，他问他的一位同学，你是做什么的？这在我的人群中绝对是标准问题。他的同学真的很生气。那位同学把脸凑到我丈夫脸前。他脸涨得通红，说，我卖马桶。他显然觉得“你是做什么的”这个问题是来自他们高中同学中几乎唯一一个来自这个蓝领铁锈地带城镇并取得成功的人的阶级侮辱。而这真正向你展示的是，再次回到阶级文化鸿沟。嗯，为什么我的人群？我们为什么要问对方，你是做什么的？嗯，我们这样做是因为这是一种社会展示。我是做什么的？我是法学教授。这是一种社会荣誉。“我卖马桶”的评论意味着我不仅仅是那个卖马桶的人。不要只把我归结为我的工作。我的工作不是我的全部。而且这也表明那个人需要保持与家乡的亲近，在一个认识他卖马桶的朋友和熟人的小圈子里。他的社会荣誉是不可携带的。人们经常注意到的一件事是，城市地区和农村地区之间存在政治鸿沟，但我从你的书中得到的一点是，鸿沟实际上是在那些世界观具有世界主义色彩的人和那些不是的人之间。所以会有一些人
of their high school class from this blue collar rust belt town that had made it. And what that really shows you is the again going back to the class culture gap. Well, why does my crowd? Why do we ask each other, what do you do? Well, we do because it's a form of social display. What do I do? I'm a law professor. That's a form of social honor. What the I sell toilets comment meant is that I'm not just the man who sells toilets. Don't just boil me down to my job. My job is not who I am. And also it shows that that guy needed to keep close to home in a small circle of friends and acquaintances who knew else toilets. His social honor is not portable. One of the things that people have often noticed is that there is a political gap between
非常适应在华盛顿或纽约工作，或者明天在伦敦或上海工作，但英国和美国也有一些人以一种非常不同的方式扎根于他们的社区。在某种程度上，他们怨恨那些世界主义者，因为他们可以随时离开，而且他们不像他们那样对当地社区有同样的联系或同样的义务。
urban areas and rural areas, but one of the things that took away from your book is that the gap is really between people who are cosmopolitan in their outlook and people who are not. So there are going to be people who are veryopolitan in their outlook and people who are not. So there are going to be people who are very much at home working in Washington or New York or working tomorrow in London or Shanghai, but there are also people in the UK and in the US who are rooted to their communities in a way that's very different. And in some ways they resent the people who are cosmopolitan because they can pick up and leave and they don't have sort of the same ties or the same obligations to local communities that they feel that they do.
这非常、非常正确。我的意思是，它确实映射到了阶级上，但英国脱欧和特朗普的当选都是被遗忘地区的反抗。例如，如果你看看投票给克林顿的县，大约有500个县。2600个县投票给了特朗普，但投票给克林顿的500个县代表了三分之二的GDP。投票给特朗普的2600个县只代表了三分之一。那些
That's very, very true. I mean, there's, it does map onto class, but Brexit and Trump's election were both a revolt of the areas that have been left behind. For example, if you look at the counties that voted for Clinton, roughly 500 counties did. 2,600 counties voted for Trump, but the 500 counties that voted for Clinton represent two thirds of GDP. The 2,600 counties that voted for Trump represent only one third. The people
投票支持英国脱欧和特朗普的人，都是那些在经济上被抛弃、在文化上被抛弃的人，正如你指出的那样，因为这些人拥有小型的、非常本地化的、非常深厚且扎根的家庭和朋友关系网络，他们实际上，社会科学研究表明，这个群体更关注社区和团结，而专业管理精英则更关注个人成就和自我发展。
who voted both for Brexit and for Trump were those people who were left behind economically and left behind culturally as you point out because these are people who have the small, very localized, very deep and rooted clique networks of family and friends they've known forever, they actually, social science studies show that this group is more focused on community and solidarity in contrast to the professional managerial elite who are more focused on individual achievement and self-development.
当你思考蓝领美国和精英们与工作的关系时，我想在某种程度上回到你丈夫与他老同学的交流。在某种程度上，通过问“你是做什么的”，精英们是在问什么？是的，这是一种社会展示，但这也是一种说法，工作确实是你定义自己是谁的方式。这是你身份的重要组成部分，而正如你在书中指出的，对于蓝领美国来说，工作实际上是达到目的的手段。工作是你为了养家糊口而做的事情。所以这很复杂。
When you think about the ways Blue-Color America and the elites relate to their work, I want to go back in some ways to the exchange that your husband had with his former classmate. In some ways by asking what do you do, elites are asking what another yes, it's a form of social display, but it's also a form of saying, work is really how you define who you are. It's an important part of your identity, whereas as you point out in the book for blue-collar America, work is really a means to an end. Work is what you do to support your family. So it's complicated.
努力工作在两个群体中都受到重视，这是我们应该开始在两个群体之间架起桥梁的关键方式之一。但努力工作的问题在于坚持不懈，尽管你可能有点讨厌这份工作，但为了养家糊口并为他们提供一个安定的家庭生活。精英们完全被他们的工作所定义。你知道，我是什么？我是律师。我是技术人员。这种完全根据工作进行的自我定义是精英的标志性元素之一。
Hard work is valued among both groups and that's one of the key ways we should begin to forge a bridge between these two groups. But the hard work is a matter of persevering and staying in that job despite the fact that you may kind of hate it in order to support your family and provide them with a settled family life. Elites are completely defined by their jobs. You know, what am I? I am a lawyer. I am a techie. This total self definition in terms of your job is one of the emblematic elements of
许多人，可能是蓝领阶层的人，认为精英只是一群可怜的、权力饥渴的文职人员，他们一生都在互相拍马屁，并把工作和生活混为一谈。在教育价值方面也存在巨大的阶级鸿沟。许多富裕的人认为教育是通往更好生活的关键，如果你想出人头地，你需要接受良好的教育。但正如你在书中指出的，琼，这个想法在白人工薪阶层中是一个更具争议的想法。
the elite. Many people may be blue-collar folks think the elite is just a bunch of sort of pathetic power-hungry pencil pushers who spend their whole life sucking up to each other and confuse their jobs with their lives. There's also a huge class divide when it comes to the value of education. Many well-to-do people believe that education is the key to a better life, that if you want to get ahead, you need to get a good education. But as you point out on the book Joan, this idea is a much more controversial idea among the white working class.
为什么？对这些群体来说，上大学真的、真的很冒险。首先，当然，大学债务近年来翻了两番。所以开始上大学风险很大。他们中的许多人最终辍学了。阶级移民，即来自非精英背景的人，辍学率要高得多。所以他们经常最终背负巨额大学债务，
Why? Going to college is really, really risky for these groups. First of all, of course, college debt is what quadrupled in recent years. So it's very risky to start to go to college. Many of them ultimately drop out. There's a much higher dropout rate among class migrants, people from non-elite backgrounds. So often they end up paying back large college debts
却拿着高中毕业生的工资。他们看到了这一点。他们认为这非常、非常冒险。此外，他们通常进不了同样的大学。社会科学研究表明，如果你给人们一份完全相同的学校记录，一份来自精英家庭，一份来自白人工薪阶层家庭，白人工薪阶层家庭的孩子实际上必须比精英家庭的孩子优秀三倍，才能被视为同样强大。这还没完。在一项研究中，琼说，研究人员向雇主发送了两套简历。
on the wage of a high school graduate. And they see that. They see it as very, very risky. In addition, that they typically don't get into the same colleges. And social science studies show that if you give people an identical school record, one from an elite family and one from a white working class family, the white working class family has to, kid, has to actually be about three times as good as the elite family kid in order to get to be seen as equally strong. It doesn't end there. In one study, Jones says, researchers sent out two sets of resumes to employers.
简历完全相同，只有一个区别。一套散发出蓝领信号，比如皮卡足球、乡村音乐。另一套散发出精英信号，水球、古典音乐。“水球先生”得到的回调次数是“乡村音乐先生”的16倍。所以你可能经历了所有这些过程，背负了所有这些债务，然后因为，怎么说呢，你不知道该用哪把叉子，你可能还是得不到一份专业工作。琼·威廉姆斯认为，这些不仅植根于经济困难，而且植根于心理羞耻和文化羞辱的阶级差异，在政治中发挥了作用。
The resumes were identical, except for one difference. One set off blue collar signals like pick up soccer like country music. The other set off elite signals, water polo, classical music. Mr. Water Polo got 16 times the number of callbacks as Mr. country music. So you may go through all of this process, incur all of this debt, and then because, you know, so to speak, you don't know what fork to use, you may not get a professional job anyway. John Williams argues that these class differences rooted not just in economic hardship, but in psychological shame and cultural humiliation play out in politics.
回来后，我们将探讨关于为什么白人工薪阶层将2016年总统大选推向唐纳德·特朗普的不同理论。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。这里是NPR。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们正在与加州大学黑斯廷斯法学院的法学教授琼·威廉姆斯交谈。她也是《白人工薪阶层：克服美国的阶级无知》一书的作者。特朗普与众不同，因为他不需要对任何捐赠者负责。他说出了我一直梦想有人会说的一切。所以2016年，一位纽约亿万富翁出现，告诉白人工薪阶层他们将不再被遗忘。
When we come back, we'll explore different theories about why the white working class tipped the 2016 presidential election to Donald Trump. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're talking with Joan Williams, a law professor of the University of California, Hastings College of the Law. She's also the author of the book, White Working Class, overcoming class cluelessness in America. Trump is different because he doesn't have to answer to any donors. He said everything I've always dreamed someone would say. So in 2016, a New York billionaire comes along and tells the white working class they're going to be forgotten no more.
你讲述的故事与唐纳德·特朗普的崛起有何交集？我认为关于为什么白人工薪阶层如此强烈地支持唐纳德·特朗普，特别是在这些被遗忘的地区，最重要的洞察力体现在一个写着“我们用中指投票”的标语上。唐纳德·特朗普就是他们的中指。他们看到了唐纳德·特朗普身上任何有眼睛的人都能看到的缺点，但我认为他们投票给他，并且对他如此忠诚，因为他就是他们的那个东西。他是对美国精英的一个巨大的“去你的”。而且他在这方面非常有效。现在这就是为什么这些中产阶级家伙对特朗普非常、非常忠诚。他在蓝领女性或蓝领家庭的女性中并不那么受欢迎。
How does the story that you tell intersect with the rise of Donald Trump? I think the most important insight into why the white working class broke so strongly for Donald Trump, particularly in these left behind areas, is epitomized by a sign that said we voted with our middle finger. Donald Trump is their middle finger. They see the warts in Donald Trump that anybody with eyes sees, but I think that they voted for him and they have been so loyal to him because that's what he is for them. He is a big fuck you to the elites in the United States. And he's really effective at that. Now that is why these middle class guys are very, very loyal to Trump. He is not as popular among blue collar women or women in blue collar families.
所以有一种因为无法获得蓝领养家糊口的工作而无法成为一个完整男人的感觉。而且因为你被许多文化产物侮辱了。自2016年大选以来，关于白人工薪阶层写了很多东西，琼，我想主要有两种论点。第一种是你和像阿莉·霍克希尔德（我们之前在《隐藏的大脑》中介绍过）这样的研究人员所支持的，即特朗普是白人工薪阶层美国对多年羞辱和忽视的回应。但还有另一种理论，它……（音频片段：所有国家都把他们送到这里来。他们又小又……他们是来自卡拉博内斯的西班牙人……他们是……他们都来到这里，他们都可以自由地生活在自己的秘密区域。当他们感到安全时，如果你进去，他们就会打破你的头。这就是让美国伟大的原因，伙计。）
So there's that sense of not being able to be a full man because you couldn't get that blue collar breadwinner job. And because you're been insulted by lots of cultural artifacts. A lot has been written about the white working class since the 2016 election zone and I would say there are two main lines of argument. The first that's espoused by you and researchers like Arlie Hopeshield whom we previously featured on Hidden Brain is that Trump was white working class America's response to years of humiliation and neglect. But there's also another theory and it And all the nations sent them in here.
所以琼，种族怨恨或仇外心理在多大程度上解释了白人工薪阶层的政治选择？我认为经济匮乏、阶级文化鸿沟和种族焦虑，它们是同一枚硬币的不同
They come small and in my dance. They're Spanish piars from the Calabones. They're jacks, you're Chinom, you're crouching your heaves, and you're leaving space. They're all come in here, and they're all free to live in their own secret sections. When they feel safe and then bust your head if you go in there. That's what makes America great, buddy. So Joan, how much does racial resentment or xenophobia explain the political choices of the white working class? I think the economic deprivation, the class culture gap, and the racial anxiety, they are different
侧面。当然，对于一个花了大半辈子研究性别和种族的人来说，有白人的地方，就有种族主义。这只是事实。无论谁表达种族主义，宽恕它都不是我的工作职责。否认种族主义在美国生活中的影响也不是我的工作，那将是疯狂的。另一方面，我认为谴责别人的种族主义比面对自己的阶级优势要容易得多。
sides of the same coin. Certainly, for someone who's spent much of my life studying gender and race, where you have white people, you have racism. That's just the fact. And it is not my job description to condone racism, no matter who expresses it. And it is not my job to deny the influence of racism in American life, that would be insane. On the other hand, I think that it's a lot easier to decry someone else's racism than to face your own class advantage.
我认为对我来说，核心在于，如果人们无法获得希望，他们就会靠恐惧生活。这就是经济焦虑和种族主义之间的联系。给人们提供一种机制来理解为什么他们感到如此……如此经济匮乏、如此漂泊的另一种方式是说，你没有得到很好的对待。在经济上，你在流行文化中没有得到很好的对待。你因为阶级不同而受到不尊重。这不是因为你是白人。这是因为你是我们的蓝领阶层。
I think that really for me the nub is that if people can't access their hope, they live by their fear. And that's the link between the economic anxiety and the racism. An alternative way of giving people a mechanism for understanding why they feel so dist, so economically bereft, so adrift is to say you haven't been well treated. By the economy, you haven't been well treated in popular culture. You have been disrespected because you're of a different class. And it's not because you're white people. It's because you are our blue-collar people.
我们将停止那样做。琼·威廉姆斯研究美国的性别、阶级和工作。她是《白人工薪阶层：克服美国的阶级无知》一书的作者。琼，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。这是我的荣幸和快乐。谢谢。我们现在转向关于特朗普基本盘动机的另一个视角。白人工薪阶层是工薪阶层，但他们也是白人，在过去半个世纪里，白人选民身上发生了一些戏剧性的事情。玛丽莎·阿布拉哈诺是加州大学圣地亚哥分校的政治学家。她与佐尔坦·海诺尔合著了《白人反弹：移民、种族和美国政治》一书。
And we're gonna stop doing that. Joan Williams studies gender, class, and work in the United States. She is the author of the book, White Working Class, Overcoming Class Cluelessness in America. Joan, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. My honor and my pleasure. Thank you. We're going to turn now to another perspective on the motivations of the Trump base. The white working class is working class, but it is also white, and something dramatic has happened with white voters over the last half century. Marissa Abrahano is a political scientist at the University of California San Diego. Along with Zoltan Heineau, she is co-author of the book, White Backlash, Immigration, Race, and American Politics.
玛丽莎说，过去40年来，白人选民从民主党转向共和党的过程非常剧烈。是的，确实如此。所以我认为我们在过去三到四十年中经历的最大转变之一是民主党和共和党选民的种族和民族构成。这很大程度上与白人正在背离民主党并坚定地与共和党结盟有关，而民主党则成为了今天在民族和种族上更加多元化的政党。
Marissa says the shift of white voters from the Democratic to the Republican Party has been dramatic over the last 40 years. Yes, indeed. So one of the biggest shifts I think that we have experienced in the last three to four decades are the racial and ethnic compositions of who makes up democratic and republican voters today. And much of that has to do with the fact that whites are defecting away from the Democratic Party and solidly aligning themselves to the Republican Party whereas the Democratic Party is the party that has become much more ethnically and racially diverse today.
所以有色人种正在向民主党靠拢，而白人正在向共和党靠拢，这不是什么新发现，但你认为，玛丽莎，这一趋势的很大一部分是由一个特定的政治问题驱动的。是的。所以我的同事是佐利·海诺尔。这就是这本书的主要论点，即移民问题是导致白人选民背离民主党的主要因素之一。
So the fact that people of color are gravitating toward the Democratic Party and whites are gravitating toward the Republican Party, this isn't a new finding, but you argue, Marissa, that a significant portion of this trend is being driven by one specific political issue. Yes. So my colleague is Zoli Hainollani. That is the main thesis of this book, is that the issue of immigration is one of the main factors that's driving white voters away from the Democratic party.
结果我们看到，我们确实正在经历这种政党重组，如果可以这样说的话，即我们两大政党的民族和种族构成。所以你们并不是第一批认识到移民在政治中很重要的学者，但当我读你们的书时，我感到震惊，你们对移民到底有多重要有了新的理解。没错。所以移民很重要并不是什么新发现。我们早就知道了，但我认为我们
And as a result of what we're seeing, we are definitely having this realignment, if you will, of the ethnic and racial makeup of that are two major political parties. So you are not the first scholars to identify that immigration matters in politics, but as I read your book, it struck me, you've come to a new understanding of just how much immigration matters. That's right. So it's not this novel finding that immigration matters. We've known that for a long time, but I think what we're
真正试图推动的是，这个美国政治中非常核心的部分，党派偏见，以及我们认为对人们在政治中如何表现的每一种解释都如此核心的东西，它确实正在被人们对移民的看法所极大地塑造。政治学中关于党派偏见的影响一直存在长期争论。我记得多年来与许多专家交谈过，他们说党派偏见和政党忠诚是一种如此强大的力量。以至于我们许多人往往在
really trying to push forward is that this very essential piece of American politics, partisanship, and something that we hold so central to every sort of explanation of how people behave in politics, that that is really, it's being tremendously shaped by how folks think about immigration. There's been a long-standing debate in political science about the effects of partisanship. I remember talking to a number of experts over the years who've said partisanship and party loyalty is such a powerful force. That many of us often arrive at our views on policy matters
宣誓效忠一方或另一方之后，才得出我们在政策问题上的观点。这几乎就像支持一支运动队。你决定支持一支运动队，然后你开始喜欢这支运动队所做的一切。这个论点会认为人们对移民的看法是由他们的党派忠诚所塑造的。
after we have pledged our allegiance to one side or the other. It's almost like following a sports team. You decide to follow a sports team and then you start to like all the things that the sports team does. And this thesis would argue that people's views on immigration are shaped by their partisan loyalties.
换句话说，人们先决定党派忠诚，然后这决定了他们如何看待移民。在某种程度上，你是在争论相反的情况。你说人们如何看待移民塑造了他们看待政党的方式。是的。所以任何研究人员选择研究党派偏见时，它总是这种非常令人生畏的力量，因为正如你所说，关于它的研究太多了，我们觉得这是我们非常了解的一件事。但同样，当我们开始进行所有这些数据分析，观察美国选民的表现时
In other words, you'd people decide that party loyalties first and that decides how they think about immigration. In some ways, you're arguing the opposite. You're saying how people think about immigration shapes the way they think about party. Yeah. So anytime any researchers choose to study partisanship, it's always this very intimidating force because, as you said, there's so much research on it, and we feel like this is the one thing that we know so much about. But again, when we started doing all this data analysis, looking at how American voters behaved
在过去20年里，非常引人注目的是，即使我们取，比如说，他们在总统大选或任何选举前两年对移民的看法，那仍然会是他们随后选举中投票选择的非常强有力的预测指标，这意味着移民解释了党派偏见，而不是相反。让我们退后一步，描绘一下你们是如何得出这个论点的。你说自2000年以来，美国吸收了数量惊人的移民。
over the past 20 years, it was really remarkable that even if we took, say, how they felt about immigration two years prior to a presidential election or any election, that that would still be a very strong predictor of their vote choice in that subsequent election, which means to suggest then that it was immigration that was explaining partisanship as opposed to vice versa. Let's step back for a second and just paint a picture of how you've arrived at this thesis. You say that since 2000, the United States has absorbed an extraordinary number of immigrants.
在某种程度上，如果这种激增没有对政治产生深远影响，那将是非常令人惊讶的。完全正确。像加利福尼亚州、德克萨斯州这样的州，我们已经是多数少数族裔州，这意味着人口的大多数由有色人种组成，其中大多数是移民后裔。所以美国人口普查预测，到2050年，每四个美国人中就有一个将是拉丁裔或西班牙裔。我的意思是，这相当令人震惊。
And in some ways, it will be very surprising if this surge did not have a profound effect on politics. Exactly. States like California, Texas, we already are majority, minority states, meaning that the majority of the population are made up of people of color, most of whom are immigrant descendants. So the U.S. Census predicts that by 2050, one out of every four Americans are going to be of Latino or Hispanic origin. I mean, that's quite astonishing.
所以虽然美国有大量移民家庭，但正如你指出的，这些家庭在投票人口中所占比例相对较小。在某种程度上，这就是你们书的核心摩擦和紧张的来源。没错。而且，你知道，我认为部分原因是这是一个公众很容易理解的问题。非法移民是一个非常简单的问题，因为对于
So while there are these large numbers of immigrant families in the United States, these families, as you point out, account for a relatively small share of the voting population. And in some ways, this is the source of the friction and tension that's at the heart of your book. That's right. And, you know, I think part of it is that it is an issue that is easily understood by the public. The fact that undocumented immigration is a very easy issue in the sense that for the
普通美国选民来说，你可以理解那些违法并在没有适当文件的情况下进入这个国家的人。这是对我们法律和秩序的违反，这很容易激发人们的情绪。而且在我看来，这与保罗·肖·玛丽莎所说的密切相关，一半的美国白人似乎认为移民是美国社会的负担。而且大多数人认为拉丁裔增加了犯罪问题。没错。
average American voter, you can understand somebody who breaks the law and enters the country without proper documentation. And that is a violation of our laws and orders that that can easily animate people. And it seems to me that's closely connected with what Paul Schoemurissa, half of white Americans seem to believe that immigrants are a burden to US society. And it's like majority think that Latinos add to the crime problem. That's right.
同样，如果你真的看数据本身，这些看法并不是现实，特别是在犯罪方面。所以就像现在政治中发生的许多事情一样，人们感知到的、真相是什么、事实是什么，与实际证据是非常不同的。玛丽莎·阿布拉哈诺和佐尔坦·海诺尔认为，人口结构的快速转变
And again, if you actually look at the data itself, those perceptions are not the reality, particularly when it comes to crime. So just like many things that's happening right now in politics, what people perceive, what the truth is, and what the facts are, are very different from what the actual evidence is. Rapid demographic shifts, Merissa Abraham and Zoltan Hainal argue,
在白人选民，尤其是白人工薪阶层中制造了威胁感。这些威胁以不同的形式出现。文化威胁。如果你不说英语且不做出贡献，是的，就是那样。经济威胁。就我而言，他们还在抢工作。政治威胁。
have created feelings of threat among white voters, especially the white working class. These threats come in different forms. Cultural threat. If you don't speak English and don't contribute, yeah, that. Economic threats. As far as I'm concerned, there's still in jobs. Political threats.
为什么国会的共和党人不理解这些政策对国家和他们自己构成的威胁。所以你同时有多种趋势在发生。一方面，你有这些快速的人口结构转变。你也有许多白人选民中日益增长的威胁感。同时，你也有一种情况，即一个政党被认为比另一个政党更能响应白人选民的焦虑。没错。我认为共和党人确实考虑了所有这些多种因素，并利用它来利用一个核心信息和主题，这确实可以再次动员
Why don't Republicans on the Hill understand the threat that these policies pose to the country and to them. So you have multiple trends happening at the same time. On the one hand, you have these rapid demographic shifts. You also have these increasing feelings of threat among many white voters. And simultaneously, you also have a situation where one political party is seen as being more responsive to the anxieties of white voters than the other one. That's right. I think the Republicans have really taken all of these multiple factors into consideration and used it to capitalize on a central message and theme that can really, again, mobilize
他们的选民。而且他们的基本盘绝大多数是白人，这意味着他们可以有一个核心信息，比如移民，可以激活并动员他们的选民，不仅支持他们的候选人，还支持他们想要倡导的各种议题。有人批评说，嗯，这是一个短期策略，他们未来会受苦，这可能是真的，但就目前而言，正如我们所见，这是一个极其成功的策略。你们还研究了当各州的人口结构开始变化时会发生什么。所以，例如，随着各州拉丁裔人口开始增加，你们在……方面发现了什么？
their voters. And the fact that their base is overwhelmingly white means that they can have a central message such as immigration that can activate and mobilize their voters into not only supporting their candidates, but also supporting the kinds of issues that they want to advocate for. There's been some criticism that, well, this is a short-term strategy and they're going to suffer in the future, and that may be the case, but for the present, it's an extremely successful strategy as we've seen. You've also looked at what happens in states as the demographics of states start to change. So, as the Latino populations in states starts to increase, for example, what do you find in terms
他们的选民。而且他们的基本盘绝大多数是白人，这意味着他们可以拥有一个核心议题，比如移民，这不仅能激活和动员他们的选民去支持他们的候选人，还能支持他们想要倡导的各种议题。有人批评说，这是一种短期策略，未来会让他们受损，这或许是真的，但就目前而言，正如我们所见，这是一种极其成功的策略。你也研究过当各州人口结构开始发生变化时会发生什么。例如，随着各州拉丁裔人口开始增加，你在这些方面发现了什么
of the behavior of white voters? Well, what you typically see is that as the population of Latino voters have increased, you start to see the shift in the political behavior of white voters to support the Republican candidate. And that would be consistent with the theory the immigration is explaining the voting preferences of white voters. You know, we wrote this book before the 2016 election. So for better or worse, some would say that it was pre-scient of the outcome, but it was just remarkable to us that when we were putting together this book and our analysis
关于白人选民的行为？嗯，你通常会看到，随着拉丁裔选民人口的增加，你开始看到白人选民的政治行为发生了转变，转而支持共和党候选人。这与移民解释白人选民投票偏好的理论是一致的。你知道，我们在2016年大选前就写了这本书。所以不管好坏，有些人会说这是对结果的预见，但对我们来说，在整理这本书和我们的分析时，这确实非常引人注目。
is that from all these different angles, not just of, you know, who white voters supported, but also the kinds of policies that they favor, that it was really just, that immigration was such a strong and important predictor in all of these different political outcomes that we were exploring. And so I think that's where this idea that it was really this white backlash towards immigration that's currently the political climate we live in today. When we come back, what Marissa Abrahamos thesis
从所有这些不同的角度来看，不仅仅是关于白人选民支持谁，还有他们偏好的政策类型，移民确实是我们在探索的所有这些不同政治结果中一个非常强大且重要的预测指标。所以我认为，这就是为什么这种观点认为，这实际上是白人对移民的强烈抵制，这正是我们今天所处的政治气候。当我们回来时，玛丽莎·阿布拉哈诺的论文
about a white backlash means for politics and elections. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're talking with Marissa Abrahamos, a political scientist at the University of California, San Diego. She is the co-author, along with Zoltan Heinell, of the book White Backlash, Immigration, Race, and American Politics. Marissa, your book came out in 2015, but as you said, in many ways it anticipated the Central Issue and Donald Trump's presidential campaign.
关于白人抵制对政治和选举意味着什么。请继续收听。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们正在与加州大学圣地亚哥分校的政治学家玛丽莎·阿布拉哈诺交谈。她是与佐尔坦·海内尔合著的《白人抵制：移民、种族与美国政治》一书的合著者。玛丽莎，你的书出版于2015年，但正如你所说，它在许多方面预见了核心议题和唐纳德·特朗普的总统竞选。
At the time, Marissa, many pundits, Trump was running a campaign that was out of touch with a diverse America. But in many ways, your book shows he was actually running a campaign that was perfectly in touch with the anxieties of white voters. That's right. I think what Pundits missed is that Trump isn't trying to attract all voters across the United States. He knew exactly what demographic and what base he was speaking to.
当时，玛丽莎，许多权威人士认为，特朗普正在进行的竞选活动与多元化的美国脱节。但在许多方面，你的书表明他实际上是在进行一场与白人选民的焦虑完全契合的竞选活动。没错。我认为权威人士错过的是，特朗普并没有试图吸引美国各地的所有选民。他非常清楚自己在对什么样的人口和基础说话。
And so again, with these kinds of emotional appeals that are tied to a specific group of individuals, that pitch, that message resonated as we all know now extremely well with his supporters. And I think it was compounded also by the fact that we had eight years in Obama presidency. And so its immigration also tied in with the issue of race. And this is why the subtitle of our book is immigration race and politics because the two things, at least in the context of the United States, they go hand in hand with one another. And so you have eight years of the presidency of the first African-American
所以，再次强调，通过这些与特定群体个人相关的情感诉求，这种推销和信息，正如我们现在所知，在他的支持者中产生了极大的共鸣。我认为这还因为我们经历了八年的奥巴马总统任期，所以移民问题也与种族问题联系在一起。这就是为什么我们书的副标题是移民、种族和政治，因为这两件事，至少在美国的背景下，是齐头并进的。所以你有八年的第一位非裔美国人总统任期，
president in this country coupled with the specific campaign message of immigration, all together tying in a lot of that racial resentment that happened in that past eight years. I think it just is what galvanized his campaign and his presidency. So one disturbing implication from your thesis, Marissa, is that we're heading to a situation where we have different political parties for people of color and people who are white. And increasingly, what this means
再加上移民这一特定的竞选信息，所有这些都将过去八年中发生的许多种族怨恨联系在一起。我认为这正是激发了他的竞选和总统任期的原因。那么，玛丽莎，你的论文中一个令人不安的含义是，我们正走向一个为有色人种和白人分别拥有不同政党的局面。而且，这越来越意味着
is that our political divides become racial divides. Indeed. And that's one of the, again, more pessimistic outcomes of this research is that really, you know, race, as we all know, is such a fundamental cleavage in our society. But I think also Republicans willingly took on that strategy and are using it to their advantage clearly. There's an interesting tension here. It seems to me for both the Democratic Party and the Republican Party, you know, we alluded to this some time earlier, but what might be in the interest of each party in the short term might not be in its interest in the long term.
我们的政治分歧变成了种族分歧。确实。这是这项研究中比较悲观的结果之一，因为正如我们所知，种族是我们社会中一个如此根本的分裂。但我认为共和党人也心甘情愿地采取了这种策略，并显然利用它来为自己谋利。这里存在一种有趣的张力。在我看来，对于民主党和共和党来说，我们之前提到过这一点，但各党在短期内的利益可能并不符合其长期的利益。
Can you talk about that from the point of view of both the Democratic Party and the Republican Party? Sure. I mean, for the Republican Party, right now, they're an overwhelmingly white party. And as we know, with the way demographics are shifting in the United States, we're going to become increasingly a majority minority country, that at some point that strategy is going to be short-lived, right? So, but again, for the time being, for the next five to ten years, it works. So, I think their sense is, well next five to ten years, it works. So I think their sense is, well, let's just go with it, right?
你能从民主党和共和党的角度谈谈这一点吗？当然。我的意思是，对于共和党来说，目前他们是一个绝大多数由白人组成的政党。正如我们所知，随着美国人口结构的变化，我们终将成为一个少数族裔占多数的国家，在某种程度上，这种策略将是短暂的。但是，再次强调，目前在未来五到十年内，它是有效的。所以，我认为他们的感觉是，好吧，未来五到十年内它是有效的。所以我想他们的感觉是，好吧，我们就顺其自然吧，对吧？
They're not looking further beyond 20, 30 years from now. On the other hand, the problem that Democrats faced is, yes, they're the most diverse party that more diverse than Republicans. But one thing that they really are struggling with is that the voting behavior of voters of color differ in the sense that so many of them are not engaged in the political process, meaning that it is very time intensive and it's very costly to get voters of color to turn out to vote. So again, we still have like a 20 to 30 percentage point difference in turnout rates between voters of color and white voters.
他们并没有看得更远，超越20、30年之后。另一方面，民主党面临的问题是，是的，他们是最多元化的政党，比共和党更多元化。但他们真正挣扎的一件事是，有色人种选民的投票行为有所不同，因为他们中有许多人没有参与政治进程，这意味着让有色人种选民出来投票非常耗时且成本高昂。所以，我们有色人种选民和白人选民之间的投票率仍然存在20到30个百分点的差距。
And so the problem that Democrats have is to how do they actually get their voters to get out there and participate in politics so that their numbers actually match their rates of turnout. That's the biggest thing that Democrats are struggling with. I'm wondering if you can tell me a little bit about this other work you've done, Marissa, that looks at this idea that the things that happen at certain moments in our lives, especially when we're young adults, have these profound effects on our political allegiances over the next several decades.
所以民主党面临的问题是，他们如何真正让选民走出来参与政治，使他们的人数与投票率相匹配。这是民主党目前最挣扎的事情。我想知道你是否能告诉我一些你所做的其他工作，玛丽莎，它关注的是这样一种观点，即在我们生命中某些时刻发生的事情，特别是在我们年轻时，会对我们未来几十年的政治忠诚产生深远的影响。
And you've studied the effects of various immigration bills starting with a bill in 1965 and one in the 1980s and one in the 1990s and one of the early 2000s. And you look at how the debate over those bills has reshaped the political allegiances of young people in each of those eras in a way that's very profound and very long-lasting. Can you talk about this process of how this crystallization of political attitudes happens? Yeah, I'm glad you've raised that point because it's a, I think it's a very important thing to bring up, especially if you think about long-term future effects. And what my research has shown is that these galvanizing, these really major moments, for example, the election of President Trump,
你研究了各种移民法案的影响，从1965年的法案开始，还有80年代、90年代和21世纪初的法案。你研究了围绕这些法案的辩论如何以一种非常深刻且持久的方式重塑了每个时代年轻人的政治忠诚。你能谈谈这种政治态度结晶的过程是如何发生的吗？是的，我很高兴你提出了这一点，因为我认为这是一个非常重要的话题，特别是如果你考虑到长期的未来影响。我的研究表明，这些激发性的、非常重大的时刻，例如特朗普总统的当选，
I would say, would mark one of them. And particularly the anti-immigrant sentiment, anti-Mexican sentiment that he's taken on really has the ability and power to shape how young voters think about politics and affiliate themselves politically, not just now, but for the rest of their future. And so the research typically thinks about this is called these moments of political crystallization, so really major events like this,
我认为，将标志着其中之一。特别是他所采取的反移民情绪、反墨西哥情绪，确实有能力和力量塑造年轻选民对政治的看法以及他们的政治归属，不仅是现在，而且是他们未来的余生。因此，研究通常认为这被称为政治结晶时刻，所以像这样非常重大的事件，
the Vietnam Wars, been something that's been studied. And so, so young folks who've been socialized in this current era, young folks generally, we think about that between the ages of 18 to 35, if they were of that age in this time period, that that's really going to have a very strong predictive power in how and who they support politically for the rest of their lives. So you can imagine that an 18-year-old senior Latino in high school, somewhere in Los Angeles, who it was his first time voting in this 2016 presidential election, hearing all this anti-immigrant sentiment is really going to shape his political views from now until the future. Marissa says that she experienced this in her own life. When she was in college, California's Republican governor Pete Wilson pushed for what was known
越南战争，一直是被研究的对象。所以，在当前时代社会化的年轻人，通常我们认为在18到35岁之间，如果他们在这个时期处于那个年龄段，那么这对他们余生在政治上支持谁将具有非常强的预测能力。所以你可以想象，一个在洛杉矶某处上高中的18岁拉丁裔高年级学生，这是他在2016年总统大选中第一次投票，听到所有这些反移民情绪，真的会塑造他从现在到未来的政治观点。玛丽莎说她在自己的生活中也经历过这种情况。当她在大学时，加州的共和党州长皮特·威尔逊推动了所谓的
as Proposition 187. It attempted to cut off health services and public education for undocumented immigrants. It passed overwhelmingly, although it was later found to be unconstitutional. Marissa, whose family immigrated to the United States from the Philippines in the 1960s, says the anti-immigrant sentiment behind the bill had a profound effect on her. You know, in a lot of immigrant homes, you don't really talk about politics all that much, or if you do, you talk about politics in your home lands. So that conversation really wasn't present at home,
187号提案。它试图切断无证移民的医疗服务和公共教育。它以压倒性多数通过，尽管后来被裁定违宪。玛丽莎的家人在20世纪60年代从菲律宾移民到美国，她说该法案背后的反移民情绪对她产生了深远的影响。你知道，在许多移民家庭中，你并不怎么谈论政治，或者如果你谈论，你谈论的是你祖国的政治。所以这种对话在家里确实不存在，
but it was evident in schools and in your communities, and especially on college campuses where you started to see what activism meant and what activism was, that's really what I started to witness how immigration played such a central role in the lives of many folks and of many Californians. And so for me that really opened my eyes to the fact that immigration really affects so many individuals at so many different levels. Did you feel in some ways the rhetoric at that time was personally directed at you that
但在学校和社区中却很明显，特别是在大学校园里，你开始看到激进主义意味着什么，激进主义是什么，这确实是我开始见证移民如何在许多人和许多加州人的生活中发挥如此核心作用的地方。所以对我来说，这确实让我大开眼界，意识到移民确实在许多不同层面上影响着许多人。你是否在某种程度上觉得当时的言论是直接针对你的，
you felt in some ways that you were the target of attack? Sure. I don't think anybody who doesn't look who's a non-white person, you know, didn't feel that way. I mean, it's just the way of it is growing up in this country. In the quarter century since Pete Wilson pushed forward Proposition 187, it isn't just Marissa whose views have cemented against the Republican Party. As white sees to be a majority in California, the state has now swung so far to the left
你是否在某种程度上觉得你是攻击的目标？当然。我不认为任何看起来不是白人的人，你知道，没有这种感觉。我的意思是，这就是在这个国家长大的方式。在皮特·威尔逊推动187号提案后的四分之一个世纪里，不仅仅是玛丽莎的观点变得反对共和党。随着白人在加州不再占多数，该州现在已经向左倾斜得如此之远，
that the Republican Party has been nearly reduced to third-party status. Democrats outnumber Republicans nearly two to one. Marissa says California offers a sobering lesson for the future of the Republican Party across the country. Yes, having again grown up in this state for all my life, it's really remarkable to see such a rapid change in my lifetime. And if you think the national parties were really
以至于共和党几乎被降级为第三党地位。民主党的人数几乎是共和党的两倍。玛丽莎说，加州为全国共和党的未来提供了一个清醒的教训。是的，再次强调，我一生都在这个州长大，在我的一生中看到如此迅速的变化确实非常了不起。如果你认为全国性政党真的
paying attention to what's happening in states like California, you would think that they wouldn't be advising the Republican candidates to use immigration, this issue, to mobilize their voters because where it alienates such a large percentage of the population. So you think it would be obvious that they would say, hey guys, this strategy is just going to, you know, come back to Baichu in the next 20 years. Don't do it. But currently, we don't see Republicans, you know, paying any attention or acknowledging the fact that
关注加州等地发生的事情，你会认为他们不会建议共和党候选人利用移民这个议题来动员他们的选民，因为它疏远了如此大比例的人口。所以你认为显而易见的是，他们会说，嘿伙计们，这个策略只会，你知道，在未来20年里反噬你们。别这么做。但目前，我们没有看到共和党人，你知道，关注或承认这样一个事实，即
this could very well be their future in the next 20 to 30 years. But there's attention, isn't it, which is if you're a Republican politician today, you are not necessarily interested in winning election 25 years from now. You need to win election today. That's right. They are current election-seeking office seekers. And so they just, all they focus on is the next election, which is typically two years or four years from now, right? So not to say that Republican strategists haven't conceded the fact that their strategies are short-term. And I remember after the 2012 election, the RNC memo came out with this acknowledgement that the party needed to
这很可能就是他们未来20到30年的样子。但这里存在一种张力，不是吗？即如果你今天是一名共和党政客，你不一定有兴趣赢得25年后的选举。你需要赢得今天的选举。没错。他们是当前的选举寻求者。所以他们只是，他们所关注的只是下一次选举，通常是两年或四年后，对吧？所以并不是说共和党战略家没有承认他们的策略是短期的。我记得在2012年大选后，共和党全国委员会的备忘录中承认该党需要
do a better job at being much more inclusive. But given that that was the minority position, we haven't really seen any kind of meaningful efforts towards that direction today. Marissa Aburjana was a political scientist at the University of California San Diego. Along with Zalton Highinal, she's co-author of the book, White Backlash, Immigration, Race, and American Politics. Marissa, thanks for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you for having me. Joan Williams and Marissa Abrahano
在更具包容性方面做得更好。但鉴于那是少数派立场，我们今天并没有真正看到任何朝着这个方向的实质性努力。玛丽莎·阿布拉哈诺是加州大学圣地亚哥分校的政治学家。她与佐尔坦·海内尔合著了《白人抵制：移民、种族与美国政治》一书。玛丽莎，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我。琼·威廉姆斯和玛丽莎·阿布拉哈诺
have looked at the very same phenomenon, the shift of white people away from the Democratic Party and toward the Republican Party and drawn very different conclusions. For Joan Williams, class prejudice against working class whites, especially from liberal elites, explains why these voters have deserted the Democratic Party. For Marissa Aburhano, racial prejudice and xenophobia are the answer.
观察到了同样的现象，即白人从民主党转向共和党，并得出了截然不同的结论。对于琼·威廉姆斯来说，对工人阶级白人的阶级偏见，特别是来自自由派精英的偏见，解释了为什么这些选民抛弃了民主党。对于玛丽莎·阿布拉哈诺来说，种族偏见和仇外心理是答案。
There is evidence to support both contentions. Indeed, as John Williams says, it may be that the loss of social honor experienced by working class whites might itself explain their shift toward the nativist vision of Donald Trump. When you can't access your hopes, all you have to live by are your fears. This week's show was produced by Thomas Liu and edited by Tara Boyle and Kimela Vargas Restrepo. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Parts Cha, and Laura Quarelle. Today's episode is the second in a two-part
有证据支持这两种论点。确实，正如琼·威廉姆斯所说，工人阶级白人所经历的社会荣誉感的丧失可能本身就解释了他们向唐纳德·特朗普的本土主义愿景的转变。当你无法获得希望时，你唯一能依靠的就是恐惧。本周的节目由托马斯·刘制作，塔拉·博伊尔和基梅拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、帕茨·查和劳拉·夸雷尔。今天的剧集是两部分中的第二部分，
look at American politics and our political identities. If you didn't catch last week's episode about the biology of our political preferences, it's really interesting. Check it out. It's the episode in your podcast feed called Red Brain Blue Brain. Our unsung hero this week is Tara Savage L. For years, Tara has run NPR's Amazing Internship program and brought literally hundreds of young journalists and public radio enthusiasts
审视美国政治和我们的政治身份。如果你没有收听上周关于我们政治偏好生物学的剧集，它真的很有趣。去看看吧。那是你播客订阅源中名为《红脑蓝脑》的剧集。我们本周的无名英雄是塔拉·萨维奇·L。多年来，塔拉一直负责NPR令人惊叹的实习项目，并带来了数百名年轻记者和公共广播爱好者
into the organization. Some of NPR's more senior reporters, hosts and managers started out as interns, so the internship program is really a way for the organization to renew itself. Tara managed the immense logistics of reviewing applications and organizing interviews, truly the definition of an unsung hero. For more hidden brain, find us on Facebook and Twitter. If you love our show, please tell one friend about us this week. In fact, try and do it right now. Think of someone who might like us and send them a note. And thanks. I'm Shankar Vidantum. See you next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
进入该组织。NPR的一些资深记者、主持人和经理都是从实习生做起的，所以实习项目确实是该组织自我更新的一种方式。塔拉管理着审查申请和组织面试的巨大后勤工作，确实是无名英雄的定义。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。如果你喜欢我们的节目，请本周告诉一位朋友。事实上，现在就试着做吧。想想可能喜欢我们的人，给他们发个便条。谢谢。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。